foreign
[Music]
The Narrative of The Lion King will be
continued unabated in a fresh prologue
to the 2019 movie version of the
animated Masterpiece which was
officially confirmed at d23 Expo 2022
with participants actually getting to
see some restricted recordings the film
is directed by Academy award-winning
Moonlight director Barry Jenkins who is
operating from a screenplay written by
Jeff Nathanson while the particular
storyline itself is being shrouded in
secrecy we do understand exactly that it
will concentrate on the protagonist lion
Mufasa's rise to become one of Pride
land's greatest heroes as depicted
Through The Eyes of fan favorites Timon
hoomba and Rafiki the movie as per
director Barry Jenkins will be
specifically told in various periods of
time as it keeps moving between both the
past and the present Mufasa was not born
into a powerful Family the movie will
depict how apparently smooth fossa
soared from The Humble Origins to emerge
as the king of Pride Rock we will get to
experience the actual Voyage of Mufasa
attempting to find his position in the
circle of life and evolving into one of
the strongest Kings To Rule The Pride
lands the Remake will indeed tell the
backstory of his brother taka as well
who will later on become the antagonist
Scar the only officially confirmed
actors for Mufasa The Lion King are
Aaron Pierre who gets to play Mufasa and
Kelvin Harrison Jr who plays Scar based
on the Hollywood reporter's news Billy
Eichner and Seth Rogen are set to return
to their roles as the dearly beloved
meerkat Timon and the warthog Pumbaa it
will be interesting to observe Mufasa
mature and try to claim his entitlement
to the king the sneak peek footage on
its own raises a lot of questions now
that we understand the major flood
abandoned Mufasa we can reach the
conclusion that scar really wasn't his
biological brother this mysterious lion
who embraced Mufasa must incorporate him
into the pride and raise him as well
along with scar who is the rightful heir
to the crown by right of birth and
considering that we all understand how
their relationship breaks down this
Narrative of Mufasa's early life could
everlastingly alter our preconceived
notions of him as well as scar Mufasa
The Lion King is scheduled to release as
a summer blockbuster in theaters July
5th 2024.
[Music]
thank you